this is own core from the United States
a global changemaker here on behalf of
the British Council I'm confident that
global growth will be restored just nine
because growth and in fact economic
performance to measure of confidence
with old leaders and old ideas we didn't
have much confidence what we did but now
we lost it we've been in my country in
the United States we have a new
administration an administration is
ready to fund infrastructure projects
pump cash I the economy would also have
regulations that both ensure that
executives are not able to swindle
markets as they have in the past but
also ensure that the American people in
fact the citizens of the world feel more
confident about what their government is
doing what's going on on Wall Street and
in their local economies